dans ce contexte monsieur alain devaquet
ministre déléguée chargée de la
recherche et de l'enseignement supérieur
a présenté ce matin sa démission chef du
gouvernement matignon explique qu'il a
été informé de l'offre de démission de
monsieur devaquet mais la réponse de
monsieur chirac n'interviendra qu'après
son retour de londres qui est située en
début d'après-midi le parcours politique
de monsieur devaquet et sa personnalité
est el ghozi l'un des rares
universitaires du gouvernement alain
devaquet 44 ans soucieux de l'avenir de
l'université des étudiants auraient sans
doute préféré convaincre qu'imposer
chaque fois qu'il en eut l'occasion
pendant le déroulement de la crise il
s'est voulu avant tout à l'écouté des
jeunes
je connais votre travail et je puis dire
que comme universitaire depuis dix ans
j'ai vu les étudiants à l'idc a
travaillé avec de plus en plus de
sérieux
le problème qui me préoccupe c'est que
une fois rentrée à l'université
il faut pas que l'étudiant père de son
temps il faut donc qu'ils soient bien
orienté physicien professeur alain
devaquet s'est rendue un jour de janvier
77 au siège du rpr pour prendre sa carte
tout naturellement les problèmes de
recherche et d'énergie nous sont confiés
jacques chirac des celles visant lui
l'oiseau rare et le propulse contre
toute attente au secrétariat général du
rpr pris entre les feux des jeunes
chirac qui est des vieux baron
l'intellectuel se sent mal à l'aise il
perd son siège de député en 80 mais sort
victorieux des municipales de 83 en
remportant la mairie du xième
arrondissement en mars dernier jacques
chirac lui confie le portefeuille de sa
compétence
la recherche et les universités et voilà
de nouveau le modéré aux prises avec les
ultra libéraux de la majorité
d'abord dans la sphère du cnrs qu'il se
refuse à démanteler et puis et surtout
sur la réforme des universités
une loi qu'il signe de son nom malgré
les points qu'ils ont tous été arrachés
des points contestés par les étudiants
et que lui-même désavouant privé
paradoxalement alain devaquet devenu
l'homme à abattre le symbole de la
sélection aux yeux des jeunes incompris
il demande aujourd'hui à quitter le
gouvernement
tout en sachant pourtant qui n'a jamais
oublié le boursier fils de boulanger
qu'il a été voilà donc pour les